evil and the one and only marilyn monroe
as a raiderette
and i just want to say i think elvis
would have been a good raider white out
those fast feet
raiders themed portraits will remind the
raider nation faithful
of their favorite silver and black
moments including super bowl memories
and victories
you can see more of this unique in
allegiant art museum and chris matthews
behind the scenes stadium tour
over on eight news now dot com
thank you brian will certainly be nice
if the raiders can pull off a win in the
home opener
they're playing a very tough new orleans
saints team tonight john treache is out
at allegiant stadium as well with the
preview hi john
welcome to las vegas home of the raiders
we can't believe that it was a hundred
years ago where we didn't say
that was even possible 20 years ago that
wasn't possible four years ago
not possible either in fact many didn't
even think this day would come a week
ago
but here we are it did we've been
baptized with big time
monday night football
few places in the world can put on a
show in the throes of a pandemic
where else can you be captivated by
aerial thrillers
musical killers and sports moment
chillers
vegas baby this city has hosted the
stanley cup a tantalizing amount of
title fights and every award show not
named oscar
but never has it showcased the nfl in a
two billion dollar man-made marvel
that's a whole new level of hype in
history
the saints and the raiders that's uh
that's monday night forward it's best
when you build a stadium like this
i mean this is the force of nature
nothing's going to stand in this way
the newest las vegas headliner has a
headset i like the old
uh monday night football anthem
to highlights with howard cosell doing
them
that was my uh monday night i look
forward to monday is a night of moments
the desire to play never goes away i'm
gonna eat dinner
and hopefully my mom already cooked
something and i'm gonna you know be able
to sit there and enjoy it with my family
and watch the game you know that's that
was
that was what we did growing up for four
years it's been we can't wait
now it's we're here and we belong
[Music]
yeah we're caught up in the sport of
spectacle of tonight well the saints
just want to
beat the tar out of the raiders so that
makes for an intriguing matchup about an
hour away
back to you